let's talk about the sort of perception
of time but what the research shows us
is the perception of experience time is
largely different by attention time
bothers us when we pay attention to it
and so the name of the game is to give
people distractions
it makes time feel like it went by
quickly okay so give your customers
something to do while waiting compare an
elevator ride some companies use music
but usually they use irritating music
but what if you you know play them the
news or some kind of interesting podcast
and then it almost becomes become
something you know it's distracting and
fun to be waiting the other thing to do
to manage time is give people a sense of
progress okay the one thing we really
don't like is not knowing right not
knowing when this thing is gonna end
actually you know Airlines used to be
bad at this you know you've had a
boarding time but it was never kind of
clear exactly when it was and now
they've shifted to telling you exactly
when the boarding time is and they even
have a countdown telling you you know
boarding is gonna commence an X amount
of minutes the exact same amount of time
where you know kind of you have a sense
of progress versus you don't have a
sense of progress feels completely
different and so you know Disney
recognizes that it has people waiting in
lines for a ton of time and so and so
what they do is they have these kind of
milepost where they say ah you know this
is this is how much time you have left
to go to give you a sense of what's
happening because we really don't like
is we don't like to have an experience
where we're we don't have control right
so so you want to give people a sense of
control what matters is not actual
control but it's your sense of perceived
control do I feel like I'm controlling
the time that's passing or is this
something else controlling it and I have
I have no no
roll over most of the time you know
customers are engaging in these
experiences and they're not they're not
cynical when I go to Disney I know
they're messing with my mind with all
the information about the waiting time
but it still works you know you can have
an objective time in which something
happened it's very different than the
subjective time in in which something
happens so the question is how do you
manage that subjective sense of of
elapsed time understand how consumers
experience and rewire your approach to
product strategy learn more about
innovative projects Eve product officer